[Music]
the first
correction is on the
clear his hand can't go outside my outer
rim because then I have two hands
working and it's not on the wui line
which is where it's supposed to be
so however I move this hand has to be
here to get both hands manipulated right
here then it'll
work no this is different that's I la la
okay you're here stay there there it
is so bring
it to the wui
line don't turn away from
it don't let it go past
you bring it right to there it is right
here two hands can
manipulate okay the second correction is
that you don't drop the
elbow with the hand they don't go
together you want the elbow to stay the
wrist is already turning wrist turns
ahead of the elbow
dropping this is
together
now this is wrist
leads wrist
leads four wrist leads oh
elbow
draw wrist leads okay wrist makes the
elbow go down not you pushing the elbow
down okay everything's in the wrist try
to let's go back a little okay this
probably should have been
0.1 but this test saki we have tons of
videos on them stop doing tesak like
fedorite iido okay
so for this arm to pass me for this arm
to have gone here in correction
one you have
to let that hand pass you already
violated the wui lung
okay so this arm is going here is the
wui
line that is where this
touches not over over here and I pass
okay so I want you to pay attention to
something Virginia you're doing this too
okay maybe this angle I don't know
figure it out okay when the
hand goes past
wui then this one cuts the distance
between our elbows is pretty
small when I bring this back the
distance is Big you see and now there's
room for the hand a lot of times people
do that and they're like I can't get
that thing off okay so it's sure when
the elbows are far apart okay all right
we're going to make sure we fix that and
then we'll continue with correction
three correction
three you can't make this pause cannot
be there cannot be a pause okay so you
can try to go
quickly but it is very good to have the
technique that I
showed
here on this technique on when we did
the YouTube video on this one I showed
you that one it is also very good to
know the one that I did earlier here so
I take a more of a
sumos it's a it's a sumos assisted by K
okay so uh you don't want to
pause you have to you can be you can go
slow but you're
fluid I don't stop he doesn't stop okay
so he's still fluid
boom
now you you can be fluid I messed up
whoa take this like everything keeps
moving okay you messed up entirely get
out of there
stop if you're quick enough you can get
it but this one is very
good okay very good because it doesn't
lose
contact right from here
it goes around to here
okay this one loses
contact even even if I try to keep my
arms here it came off a
little so I'm rolling it to there
boom okay no stopping between the uh
tabaki and the N was okay okay uh give
me a second to set this up because my Dy
don't know how to do this because it's
wrong we don't do it but I have had many
videos on
this that you cannot rotate your hips
most commonly in
Tenon
uh in a way that the reactionary force
is going to cut through your shikaku you
will lose balance okay so some common
ones is when the
the the N let me do it on this
side the
N is turning him on that ten con okay
or another one is where they go here and
turn here okay it doesn't matter if you
hop or you put your feet right or you
bend your knees all that is crap okay so
um the first one I want you to try is
where you try to turn me on the T okay
so let me just see if Taylor can do this
you're going to turn me on the T there
you go
okay so he
goes and he can't he's not going to turn
me because the reaction Force cuts
through the middle of his two feet which
is shikaku and he's going to lose
balance okay the next one I want you to
do is don't turn me here but then come
forward and then turn me on this T
okay let me see if you can do it 10 con
10 con no and 10 con good then you go
forward and 10 con to turn you
okay There He
Go
Okay
um this is a no no this does not work
okay
um so this this comes from people think
that iido is working through hip
rotation and they're like look you
rotated your hip look your emian your
Tenon you rotated your hips a lot it
does not come from hip rotation it it
comes from the qua uh Andrew's
15° okay that that's all you get that is
it it's here it's not my hips moving
through
space doesn't do that that hip that hip
rotation will always generate through
reactionary Force Through the middle of
his two feet that's the shikaku and you
will lose your balance
okay
so in this
technique you're not
going
here that would be
wrong but you're also not
going here that's wrong too that that
only works on the person who's going to
go with you and this technique is for
the UK who's not going with you okay the
person that doesn't have spinal
displacement that's going flying past
you okay all right
so uh let's watch
something
uh when I
move from where my hands can both touch
what I'm touching so the wui line the
W can make
up that 15° but if you pay
attention that meant the wui line moved
you see that I won't ever go here
okay this technique like every other
iida technique keeps on the wuji
line for his power so when uh let's say
he's pushing now's he's doing spinal
displacement
okay and I know I want to touch with
this hand then I have to move to put
those this whole mechanism on the wui
line okay now when I do the throw I
don't want to bring it off the wui
line no matter how I do that cuz here I
am not strong
okay
so
resist I am not strong there
okay um I am only strong or
strongest on the wui
line when we use the qua which some
people think is hip
rotation the whole mechanism moves with
the wui line boom
okay does that make sense my hands this
mechanism does not go left and right of
the wui line nor is there some hip
rotation that's doing this
okay so if you pay attention no matter
what I'm doing on this
technique it is on that wui line okay
every single
time here stay when I move here if I
need to it's cuz I need the wui line to
move here but he doesn't he's not
doing
that and I haven't really rotated my
hips so resist that pull you see and I'm
just grounding this foot and I
move does that make sense that is
different from resist and I'm trying to
bring him around like that I cannot do
that okay so this may look like a ten
con but if you pay attention my
hips aren't really rotating around each
other here's where the technique
is room
no okay let's try keep the technique
here the entire time okay all right so
the
pin down and we're here okay
so here uh I have the arm
vent I don't have this thing like this
okay now I know if he stays
there uh I can get this EO right here
okay and I know if he stays there I can
get that elbow but the the problem
is that he doesn't have to stay there he
can Shuffle
forward and I lose that okay so go back
to my point that the iido pins are not
pins okay they're not
pins um and this one's not a
pin I'm here like this
okay there's my this is what I
want and then I'm going to attack what I
call the scapula mechanism there's going
to be immense weight
here
shoving down that way
I want that pin or that pressure to take
slack out so look at all the slack I
want it
gone now when I move his arm this way
he'll feel it
immediately so tap when you don't like
it that's how much movement I could get
out of it okay um so that
means that when I go let's do the
technique
here when I'm
here that's that technique there's no
time for him to go forward okay that's
what I'm doing so keep that in
mind that it's not a
pin it's a dislocation
okay that's what you're trying to
do
um
secondarily note
how his tapping
signal is pre perceptible movement to
anybody out there and that is telling
you that he's already at the cusp of
this
location so when we're
here like this okay he's not at the
cusp you see how long that took to get
there
okay so that's not
correct uh the other the next point
about this is not its
immediatey but what is my actual range
of motion towards the dislocation it's
related so if he's already at the
cusp and I have the
ability to not only move to the
cusp but weigh the F down there that
thing's
dislocated if my ability I get I don't
get to the cusp it's not dislocated if I
can only get to the cusp it's not
dislocated if I get a little past the
cusp it might be dislocated okay it need
to be way down there so if we are
here and I won't get it in place but you
can
see how far I can move from where I
didn't move at all so here is where the
cus was and I moved my hands and my
Center a good foot and a half more that
thing's coming off
okay if we look at
this okay and I'm doing this
one I'm I am not the cusp of my wrist
movement if you pay attention right you
see and I am at the cusp of my energy
output he's strong strong enough on me
to actually Force his wrist back
up okay if he combines that with
if he combines that with moving forward
it's easy peasy to get out okay
so adopt the pin that we had and not a
ferite pin where they tap your pins have
to well better said your
dislocations have to feel like there is
no way I can't rip this Lim off they
cannot be just a guy tapped out
eventually because it was the OE on him
okay you that's not it at all okay um
there's a lot of people that cannot take
pain they're in
iido right so they're going to tap out
super early you you don't judge by that
crowd tapping out you judge by the
mechanics do you have the joint
compromise
to such a degree in light of what your
range of motion is and your potential
power output that you can rip it off yes
or no you don't need the tap to tell you
that okay I don't pay attention to the
tap if you if you pay attention a lot of
times I already started the next rep
before they tap because I knew all the
mechanics were in place to do whatever I
wanted to do with that okay